whitney i feel like we gotta start with
the tagline
because it's one of the best taglines of
all time
this rose isn't scared to handle a
little prick
what does that mean when you're a wild
rose you can
stand even the most aggressive
environmental
um behaviors and storms
so is it your whole cast pricking you
is it one person in particular i have
two people who just
you know whether you're seeing it or not
are relentless name names give me the
names who
are the two people we should be looking
out for we should be protecting you from
yeah i think that you should be watching
out for
my relationship with lisa and jen i
would drown her in the lake behind her
house if she wasn't your friend
pray for me did you know you were
signing up for housewives or did you
just think we're doing a reality show
reality show um i knew the concept was
to explore the new utah and then when
housewives
becomes attached what what goes off in
your brain
hell yes
i've been a housewife fan for years
so the fact that i'm sitting here
interviewing with you as a housewife
it's everything well talk to me about
how the show came to you how did you get
roped into this wild world of real
housewives
i have heather gay to thank for that one
heather and i have been friends for
years i've also known
mary prior to this but heather's the one
who i can thank for roping me into this
crazy world
i think mary's a very interesting figure
when her bio came out
when the announcement came out everyone
honed in on that one
what do we need to know about
jaw-dropping
mary cosby you're going to go with mary
to grandfather mary's someone you don't
want to write off
i think she'll surprise you because she
has so many layers let's talk about your
your other cast members i want to do
some rapid fire who's the biggest
pot stirrer in this group jen shaw why
she just okay so i can answer this two
ways i could say
who's the obvious one and then who's
behind the scenes behind the scenes i
would say
lisa barlow even though she's gonna deny
it because she loves to pull everyone
off one on one and
have manage and be the boss of
everything you know
i hold myself to a high standard if you
don't want the saint sanders go away
and then jen is just in your face
potster
because she cannot stand to not be the
center of attention
why would you even do that i could have
done want that to happen
oh my god if this girl she hates my gut
dan's a big personality
and i love attention obviously all six
of us do we're a house we're on a
housewife show
um but it's difficult for jens when the
spotlight moves to other people
who is gonna surprise us the most i hope
it's me i hope i surprise everyone
who surprised you the most of your
co-stars
meredith did i didn't expect to
build such a great connection with
meredith she
is someone who i really look up to
and she and i have this sister
like look out for each other but i don't
know if
it takes a while to see that and i don't
know if that really happened
after all of this or during or all of
the above okay so you'll learn by
watching along with us
yeah all right did anyone disappoint you
anyone that you're like wow
i can't believe you took it to that
place while we were making this show
again i have to say jen shaw yeah
give me hints as to what the big drama
of the season is going to be all about
what do we need to keep our eye on as
things build up over the course of the
season
it's a very good question you need to
keep your eye on jen and mary
and then i would just keep your eye on
kind of what i said of the pot stirring
see if you can pick up
the pieces of the not so obvious stuff
that we all do
you are the the youngin in the group
yeah how does
how does that work does that make does
everyone treat you like the little
sister the kid sister is that
part of the dynamic we'll see yes i
that's a very
very good way to explain that you know i
believe i'm
15 years younger than some of them and i
definitely get picked on like i'm the
little sister
it is so hard to be a good mormon
religion and mormonism obviously going
to be a big conversation around this
show
what do you think the biggest
misconception is about the mormon church
but i think most people know mormons
through like
sister wives on tlc exactly um
i think that people would be surprised
to know that mormons
actually live fabulous lifestyles not
everyone
is cookie cutter from um big love
it's um even though i kind of am pulling
in that vibe right now
you are ex-mormon
you have been excommunicated from the
church
not officially okay but i'm sure after
the premiere i will be
what does an unofficial excommunication
mean
an unofficial excommunication means that
you leave
by your own free will so i just stopped
going i stopped practicing um
you know i removed my mormon garments
that i was wearing which is the
underwear that you receive when you make
a commitment
in the mormon church um so yes i just
decided on my own
i wasn't forced out
which is shocking what do you think the
church is really gonna think about
real housewives of salt lake city oh
okay well let me be very careful how i
answer this
it's going to be seen in both ways i
think
of disgust or maybe a dislike but also
if it's profitable it might be a very
good thing for
salt lake city we are very excited
to travel to salt lake city utah
for the real housewives of
slc i mean we're approaching the year of
bravo even announcing the show was
happening which you guys knew it was
happening before then so what's it
been like this year of anticipation oh
so
much so many feelings like
it's been so hard because you want to
tell the world about it and you want to
be like
i'm a housewife you know and you can't
it was hard but it has
been an incredible journey so exciting
so liberating
i'm just so glad it's here did you
covertly reach out to any housewives in
other cities or hear from other
housewives be like okay i need some
advice or
what's this really like did you get any
of that yeah so
katie maloney from vanderpump wolves has
been kind of my rock
through this she um
she responds to me right away every time
i message her
any time there's as many highs there's
as many lows
and in those little moments katie's
given me the best
feeling of safety and advice did you
know her beforehand
or did you just connect with her on that
level after the fact like hey
you taught a utah girl what's up yeah so
lala and i
have mutual connections actually met
katie
through lala what's the best piece of
advice she gave you best piece of advice
is to go inward
you're gonna be so worried about the
fact that the world knows you had an
affair or
you got drunk and you threw a glass
whatever it is and
they said but people are gonna come
after you for like the type of bread
that you fed your kid
yeah it's gonna be stuff that you you
don't see coming the premiere
we get to see your vow renewal and the
story of
this marriage that's lasted ten years
and is now an institution and of itself
but started on
some shaky ground and the fact that it
was an affair on both
sides yes she fell in love with justin
they had this illicit torrid affair and
as a result
they were both excommunicated from the
church when i was watching that i go
this girl's already blown up her whole
life reality tv is nothing compared to
what she went through a decade ago
exactly you said it best um
you know bryce there's one thing that i
believe by and that's own it yes i've
already blown up my life
like in a way that's unimaginable i've
lost
family friends i've hurt tons of people
i've been judged i made that choice a
lot of people do
but a lot of people don't own it and
owning it has helped me create
a firm foundation and a stable life
but it was rocky for a while it took wit
a while to figure out who whit was after
all of that so who is wit now who do you
how do you describe yourself now
i think the best way to describe wit
is that i'm an experience and i'm
experiencing it with you
through it all i'm the luckiest person
alive to be married
to whitney rose
[Applause]
all right let's go let's party bauer
knowles don't have the best track record
on housewives whitney
i know did you have any trepidation
going in like we're doing this and
everyone who does this gets divorced
well listen
the valerie nola was happening
regardless of the show
um that was something that justin i said
we always joked that
if we made it to the 10-year mark which
in and of itself being a second marriage
and an affair
we've already beat like every odd
against us
right so here we are and we it was
important to us to celebrate that and i
didn't
get my dream wedding i've been married
twice and i've never
had the wedding i want it meant so much
to me
to walk in front of people who love and
support justin and i
and have the party i wanted to have with
a stripper pull and all
you could never leave out the stripper
pole is that permanently installed in
your house or was it special for the
party
no i have three poles actually and
they're all like portable
i was into pull fitness for a long time
and everyone can judge the pull it's
gonna be about to be the election
there's a fly
in here
um everyone can knock the pole but it is
the best
like party um trick
it gets people out of their comfort zone
and having so much fun
like i just saw the flag i know i'm like
where is that where's the shaw's
sweater the last thing that dad wants is
to call his daughter and tell her i'm a
drug addict another member of your
family who we see
in the trailer is your dad and it looks
like it's gonna be an emotional journey
with him what can you tell me about what
we're going to see
already when you said that i just felt
the wave
of emotion um it's
very raw very real
um uh
helping my dad through sobriety
at the time that we started filming was
right when he decided
he had just finished rehab 30 days of
rehab
and getting him to take the next step
from rehab to sober living was
really really hard very emotional
i can't even put it into words it's it's
just
it's it was hard very very hard
very deep but that's what makes these
shows so
amazing is it's like as much as it is
about the lifestyle and the fun and like
kind of the petty day-to-day drama
there's also those very real things that
wind up helping people
who are watching who are struggling who
need the reinforcement that i'm not
alone or i'm not the only person
who's dealing with this thing yeah and i
think that that
was the most beautiful thing that i had
to share this season because
my dad allowed me to share the story and
sobriety is an everyday thing
it's not just uh you completed this
and now you're done i mean we're still
going through it so
yeah it's not it's not something you
check off and move on it's an everyday
thing
all right let's have a little more fun
is there anything that you're super
excited for fans to get to see your
experience
i think just how amazing utah
is like we do things that other
households
don't get to do then also just how
how down and dirty we can get here
well kind of on that note is there
anything you're dreading having to
relive
or people finding out i mean in the
teaser were hinted at this whole
homewrecker swinger allegation thing do
you think your homework lisa accused me
of being a swing guard
yes i was waiting for that to come up
obviously i'm
i'm worried for that a little bit
because that is such a strong
um judgment call to make care
and you know sexuality and all of that
and to be accused of something that you
may or may not
be and then people having a problem with
it and putting it on
display it's hard i don't want to like
spoil anything but
it's probably not true i can swing
around many things but my relationship
is not one of them i feel like if it
were true you would own up to it because
of how much you lay on the line
immediately you'd be like
hell yeah i am so what yeah i'd own it
all right to wrap things up here
if you had to sum up your first season
experience on the real housewives of
salt lake city in one word
what is that word epic epic i'm ready
for it
yeah it's going to be amazing